where is your mind on  how this should be investigated and  whether there's any there there  it's always been clear to me that this  virus just like sars won before it and  all the other coronas and in fact all  the human viruses it came from a wild  animal somewhere  not from a lab no no virus that has  spread this way has ever come from a lab  which is not to say it couldn't happen  again but that lab in in wuhan was not  working on these viruses there's plenty  of evidence that they're closely related  viruses in nature and i do think that  the lab leak idea is just a distraction  politically motivated  it's an easy answer for a tough problem  it took 10 years to find the virus which  came into people for sars one and so it  might take as long to find where that  virus is the precursor we don't have  anything close to it yet it requires a  lot of wildlife sampling and if we're  gonna have  international arguments with countries  that's not going to happen